30 seconds did you ever think you were
made
Sweet Victory I know this life meant for
me yeah why would you plan on Goliath
when we got bit David now you came in
giving values contagious this world
entrepreneurs we gain no value to haters
[Music]
293 episode today with
mayor Suarez and Graham Stefan which is
a weird combination because you're
running for nothing right nothing you
happen to be a guy that's got uh you
started real estate at 18 years old I
did you've sold 130 million dollars of
real estate you got I think two YouTube
channels maybe more one of them is like
four or five million subscribers the
other one the iced coffee hour which is
phenomenal we did a podcast together so
much fun last year at MGA you're right
because I'm going to be in Vegas Monday
for artists it's Graham here so I just
wanted to share if you can lower that
Rob thank you so uh exciting to have you
on here with us and he's a boxer by the
way yeah hardcore we heard about that so
that's why a couple of guys I told them
don't mess with them watch this feedback
he did it he he did a celebrity boxing
which that's what he's here for that was
uh Adam's Main and by the way what's
interesting is he lost because he only
trained four times a week the other guy
did six days six seven yeah
serious stuff if you're gonna challenge
somebody
six or seven days and then we have uh
mayor Suarez the the gentleman who asked
the legendary question how can I help
yes right of Elon Musk on Twitter
shocking yeah
from there you know even recently I
think there was a girl that did a tweet
Rob if he can pull this up the tweet
from um
Ashley sends a tweet saying hey oh yeah
I lived in Texas my whole life I've
never really imagined living anywhere
else before but I really feel like Texas
doesn't have much here anymore any
recommendation must be crypto friendly
marijuana friendly good networking
opportunities plenty to do Elon Musk
probably Miami right yeah and this is
just three months ago by the way less
than three months ago when that happened
so musk is a big fan of you musk is a
big fan of what you guys are doing in
Miami did you know that I responded to
that I didn't see that can you go to
respond or no no it's all right well I
don't know if you can but I responded
definitely Miami definitely Miami I love
it so so American lawyer politician
serving as a 43rd mayor of Miami since
2017. son of former mayor Javier Suarez
he previously served in the Miami city
commission from 2009 to 2017 and first
elected mayor of Miami in 2017 reelected
2021 and now running for office trying
to do the impossible something that's
never ever happened since 1776 going
from mayor to president there was
another gentleman that try to do it a
guy named Pete that's right and so so
now you uh and of course it's going to
be interesting to see what happens but
it's great to have you on a podcast it's
great to be with you we call it actually
project possible instead of doing the
impossible we call it project possible
which is based on a movie
um 14 Peaks where uh a guy tries to
climb 14 mountains that are over a
certain you know altitude of thousands
of meters in a certain period of time
and they told them it was impossible and
uh 14 Peaks yeah 14. you gotta see it's
on Netflix it's really good and uh and
he did it and so nothing in life is
impossible you have to start with that
premise Big Ideas big goals Big Dreams
are all possible and you have to set a
course and you have to have a strategy
and you have to
um go there and of course um you have to
have what I call a theory of the case
right like how is it going to happen
yeah
um I think you do a lot of due diligence
I mean I'm sure in real estate you do a
ton of due diligence before you get
involved you guys do as well and then um
you know we're we're in pre-production
here sawing you guys studying and all
the work that goes in people there's
this great uh saying in the church as
they say they see the glory but they
don't know the real story right they see
the sort of the glitz the glamor all the
great stuff but they don't know how much
work goes into it and then uh you know
look it's it's the beginning of this
process like you said it's a huge
mountain to climb and uh and we'll see
how it goes I'm not gonna certain
question for you for you know everybody
will look at their campaign
is a campaign for something right you
know
I'm with her you know Hillary Clinton
first female you know Trump make America
great again and you're what is if you
were to say my campaign is around two or
three points what are those two or three
points you're campaigning behind I think
the first thing is unifying the country
the country is incredibly divided I was
blessed to be elected by 85 percent and
re-elected by 80
um we live in a world where we're
constantly fighting with each other and
I think the the only people that that
serves our enemies if you think about
you know what what is China Russia Iran
uh North Korea Cuba all our enemies uh
have in common or what do they want to
see us in terms of a democracy they want
to see the Kryptonite of democracy which
is division and we're giving it to them
um and I think uh no one is really
saying that they want to unify the
country and no one really is talking
about how they want to do that so my one
word would probably be Unity
um the other one is to believe to your
point
um you know you got to believe in the
impossible you have to believe in
America that any anything can happen
that if you work hard that if you are
talented enough that you you can
articulate a vision you can Captivate
people inspire people anything can
happen and it was interesting I was on a
fox business interview I think two weeks
ago and uh the moderator put up a
graphic uh which basically showed that
at the exact same time that I was doing
the interview in 2015 Trump was at one
percent which is sort of where I am
right
um unknown well he was known but he was
not you know he did not have high
polling and so again we forget sometimes
how many times the the country chooses
an underdog to be the president
um it's happened so many times in my
lifetime I wanna I wanna ask you a
follow-up position on that so the first
time uh Trump ran everybody's like this
is a you know this is a marketing given
yes it's not real this is this this is
that and most people don't uh realize I
think he ran in 2000 he ran in 2000 the
first time can you check to see when's
the first time you ran I think you're
right before yeah he ran the first time
2000 and everybody's like dude this guy
doesn't stand a chance there's no way
it's going to happen there's no way
there's no way that and
in this election you know you and I have
spent time together and I you know what
I respect a lot about you is I made a
video specifically dedicated to you yeah
because I I'm as a business guy I love
guys that are you know getting back to
you quick let's go let's go you and I
one day where uh use I think you DM me
on Instagram Pat can we have you on the
show Miami and then we start talking and
then I'm driving on the car in the car
calling you and we're on the phone hey
okay when I was on the call Karina well
if you can have your assistant call
Karina we'll get attempt to do the
podcast I hang up 30 seconds later your
system Rosie calls Karina they book a
time they come in I'm sitting there in
the car saying that's the kind of stuff
I don't know if this guy's gonna be a
president or not but a guy that moves
that quickly yeah you have to respect
that because sometimes the criticism of
your competitors may be they move slower
yeah you know like Vivek and I super
fast on how he communicates RFK you can
get a hold and talk to him no problem
even Trump's Camp is easier to work with
if you want to find out what's going on
there some of the camps you know know
it's not the case you know sometimes
it's tough to get a hold of the
scientist to be fair with them I've
spoken to them multiple times nothing's
happened it's just always talk and then
you know it was challenging but some say
some say for you if I'm asked the
question some say is he running because
he's running to be a president is he
running because he wants his resume to
say former presidential candidate
because if he can do it you may as well
get it out of the way sure or is he
running because I'm gonna get in the
ring I'm gonna get dirty maybe he wants
a position on Trump's cabinet the
sentences cabinet or maybe it's just
kind of like go get your nose bloody
yeah you're gonna have a bunch of tough
situations and then maybe you'll run
again 28 32-36 which one of those is it
so let me just take a step back and talk
about something that you just talked
about before I answer the question which
is you got to look at the candidates
history right and I think that speed of
response is directly correlated with the
fact that certain candidates are private
sector guys right they have that private
sector experience even me as a mayor I'm
a working mayor and I'm a working public
official for 13 years I've always been
able to work right so you have that
connection to the private sector that
instant response that don't let an
opportunity go by that how can I help
tweet that definitely Miami responds to
that tweet that's the private sector
part of you that says there's an
opportunity you gotta Jump On It when
you talk about someone like like the
governor if you look at his history no
private sector experience that's for
that I can tell right nobody's ever
really talked about that right the fact
that smart guy you know ivy league or
Harvard Yale super smart smart guy you
know come you know jog you know serves
in the military wonderful
um then from there goes to Congress I
just don't I don't see the private
sector experience so I think you know
when you're just in the public sector
all the time you don't have that same
hunger the same ferocity that same right
no one's talked about that no one has
actually mentioned that because I think
they get so caught up with his public
sector uh Bona fides and his educational
bonafides nobody actually says wait a
second this is like kind of like a Joe
Biden situation where someone has not
worked in the private sector ever and
doesn't have a connection doesn't
understand how the private sector works
I think that's part of it and I have
that private sector and I also have the
public sector I think that also
distinguishes me from someone like or
even a trump who who they have a lot of
you know dynamic idea is things that are
sort of out there right and so because
they've never worked in the public
sector when they get in they're like oh
wait a second this is a different
monster than what I thought you know for
me I have a combination of those skills
and so you to answer your question right
the specific question first of all I've
done this at a great sacrifice to myself
uh financially
um you know obviously as you know family
wise you're traveling a lot I have two
little kids a nine-year-old and a
five-year-old I was away yesterday came
back home you know and then I'm gonna be
away you know twice next week so it's a
huge sacrifice it's part of the reason
why it took me so long right it took me
a long time to decide to run for
president it wasn't like something I did
and at some level was a bit of a
disadvantage right because I could have
done it two months ago I couldn't three
months ago when vivec started when uh
when Tim Scott started when Nikki Haley
started they started months before and
and I was struggling because uh you know
I'm not as well known right I don't have
personal like massive personal wealth
where I can't get in my Jet and be like
hey I'm going to three states today
which some candidates can do and then I
didn't have 100 million 150 million
dollar War chest and you know the the
best known news channel uh in America
saying hey we want you to run we're
gonna back you we're gonna we're gonna
put all this free press behind you so
I've been I've been running a very sort
of insurgent campaign in that sense
um understanding that I've the only path
to victory for me is incremental right
it's it's going in increments in small
bites so the next increment is the
August 23rd debate I have to be on that
stage because it's the first opportunity
that I have to be on equal footing with
my let's call them competitors I don't
really think of them as competitors or
friends or good guys they're good people
that care about this country they want
to see this country go forward we may
not agree on everything but
um you know that's my first opportunity
to articulate my vision to talk about my
track record to inspire people and
connect with them right and I think
that's one of my strengths and so
that'll be and the beauty of this
process and I actually kind of like it
some people don't like it which is these
all these requirements right 40 000
contributions one percent polling I get
on the stage to get on the next stage
already saying it's 50 000 contributions
three percent pulling I actually kind of
like that because they're benchmarks
people in business understand benchmarks
you gotta hit price support levels if
you're a stock right you've got to hit
these benchmarks so that you can grow
and if you don't you're taking away time
from somebody else this is a mutually
exclusive you know zero-sum game yeah
time here is time that somebody else is
not here so so you're running you're
you're you're not running to get on a
cabinet you're not running to get your
feet wet because maybe in the future
you're going to run you're running
because you're convinced you're going to
run for president absolutely look to be
a Cabinet member will be a huge
financial sacrifice for me okay
um I'm not I'm interested in being a
legislator a senator or Congressman or
anything like that you know people have
talked about vice president and you know
I've said very honestly candidly
authentically like if somebody were to
tell me to be the vice president I
wouldn't say like oh no that's I'm too
good for that job you know what I mean
you can do Governor would you have
interest in being a governor of Florida
you know I I to be honest with you I
look at opportunities as they come right
this was an opportunity that was in
front of me right I analyzed it in front
of me
um if I do well in this opportunity
let's say it doesn't work out for
whatever reason and that's an
opportunity in the future sure I would
look at it I would look at it without a
doubt because it's a hundred billion
dollar uh you know government with 20
million people it's the third largest
state in America it's probably one of
the largest countries in the world if
you consider it a country by GDP yeah
um so it would be a tremendous
opportunity to shape the future of a lot
of of lives in the way that Government
Can can do it in a hopefully helpful way
or getting out of the way what's your
relationship with the governor you and
Governor Ron DeSantis not much have you
guys had dinner before have you broke
have you have you had a phone call
private conversation we have he called
me um during covert when I got covered I
was was actually the first person in
Miami-Dade County to get covert or at
least to test positive which is kind of
a funny story in and of itself I don't
know if you heard this story it's it's
actually hilarious uh I guess if getting
covered can be hilarious for somebody
but yeah but what happened is the
president of Brazil comes to Miami he
had actually been in Mar-A-Lago with
President Trump assistant
March 2020. correct that's right so I
got I tested positive March 12th of
2020. okay so the day of coven basically
exactly like I think it was a day the
NBA canceled the season or something
like that right so so so he comes Monday
and Tuesday with his huge delegation and
he has in the delegation obviously you
know his staff or whatever
um they leave they all leave on Tuesday
Thursday we have a council meeting and
it becomes public that his publicist or
his like Communications guy test
positive for covid so I'm like wow 150
guys what does that mean for me you know
what I mean so my my this is I don't
know if I should tell the whole story
but anyways my other Chief is telling me
you got a quarantine and again this is
the private sector what do you mean
quarantine how do I know I even was
around this guy I feel great you know
what I mean why why do I have to
quarantine well you know you got to
quarantine you got to be safe you know
blah blah
and I said yeah I don't know about that
you know I'm a worker you know it's just
sitting on the sidelines thing for 14
days you know I don't know
so then I get a call from a friend uh
who's a high-ranking public official I'm
not going to say who
um and he says hey man you're in a
picture with this guy like you're in
like he's like close to you so I was
like oh God so he sent me the picture he
texted me the picture and well no so now
now we're both so now with the guy who
was who got him oh God
right so it was a different picture but
yeah that's that that was the trip uh
when he was here I gave him the key to
the city which the mayor of New York
refused to give him so he he was always
a big fan of me and um and you know
anyhow uh it's a great story so so I I
do then in fact say yeah I'm gonna
quarantine obviously I was in a picture
with the guy I was obviously close I
didn't know who he was right and I said
hi to a lot of people so the next day I
I get up I'm at home alone and because I
couldn't go to hotel this was all public
already at this point that I had it it
was like a big mess
and I wake up and I have a missed call
because I had to go test the day before
was me Rick Scott and the county mayor
at the time was now Congressman all had
to go test right so I get up I have a
missed call and the Herald's reporting
that a 42 year old male because I guess
they wouldn't release the names tested
positive I was 42 at the time and uh so
I picked up the phone and the doctor
answers and he goes I regret to inform
you that you are positive and I go are
you sure
he goes I'm 98 sure I go no no pops you
got to be 100 sure here I have this is
pre-social distancing mask all that
stuff so I'm like I've been in contact
with thousands of people thousands of
people like this is gonna be a major
problem
um if uh you know if it turns out that
I'm positive and he goes
um I'm 100 sure just like that so yeah
that was that was that and uh Governor
called you then so he called me then
yeah and then we we maintained a bit of
a relationship you know with him it's
it's it's kind of one way you know like
it's you listen and he talks you know
kind of a relationship and uh you know
and then that was it um he
um so that that I mean we stopped
talking right around then at some point
he stopped taking my calls maybe I did
something he didn't like or something I
don't know what do you think that was
that he just wasn't who knows uh you
know his his group his people are very
fickle and and they've attacked me a lot
I don't know if it's they don't like the
the oxygen that I get the attention that
I get they don't like the fact that
people think that maybe what's happening
in Florida is in large part what's
happening in Miami all the great things
that are happening in Miami there's a
little bit of like you know you're
taking away the oxygen
um and so they kind of try to Brand me
as I'm not Republican enough or I'm not
this or I'm not that
um and so I re you know every time
something happens they start hitting me
you know you could tell it's their it's
the sort of the um the true you know
they're sort of trolls and they're
they're paid Bots and all that stuff we
shouldn't shouldn't the
governor of Florida
at some sense have a somewhat of a
relationship
with the mayor of the biggest city in
the entire State of Florida one of the
biggest cities in the country who
happens to be Republican as well
shouldn't there be some sort of
relationship and and I've always been
open to it right and look a relationship
a friendship and I think this is this is
an issue that's coming up in the
campaign sort of his limitations in
terms of building relationships and
friendships and loyalty and things like
that like to me those are the bedrocks
of friendship right friendships are
created based on loyalty based on you
know listening to people based on you
know give and take and based on you know
hey you're going to help me I'll help
you you know uh that's the way I've
always viewed it so I think what's
important for people to look at in this
campaign is
as an attribute for a presidential
candidate I think this is important for
people to say can the person build
relationships
can does the person understand
friendship why is that important well
our relationships in the Middle East are
completely destroyed they're completely
fractured if you go now we don't have a
relationship with Israel or not a great
relationship with Israel right
um the president and Bibi are not you
know they're not they're not on their
fab five right the president called the
the prime minister of Saudi Arabia a
pariah right MBS and then and then turn
around and said hey can you by the way
increase production so that we can lower
gas prices in advance of the midterm so
I can do better in the midterm and of
course the Prime Minister said no right
he's got issues in UAE he's got issues
in in in Qatar
um that I've heard from people in in you
know I've been there and I've talked to
people that have said you know the U.S
for example had asked us to criticize
the Iran deal and then they were back
door doing the Iran deal right so
they're asking us to publicly criticize
Iran and they were back to our doing a
deal with Iran so those are the kinds of
things that don't create relationships
and friendships and you don't think Ron
does that you don't think the governor
does that to build a relationship with
the Mayors I I think well he doesn't
have racial with any of Mayors maybe
with the exception of one or two uh very
few is that normal though I don't think
that's normal okay so I don't think I
would be by the way go a step further
yeah about Congressman he was a
congressman right he lost I think uh
there's 13
um endorsements that are 12 out of the
13 went to Trump I think he got one in
Florida you're in Florida
right so that that goes to show of your
Congressman check that guy rob you can
check it that was his Congressional
block that used to carry him correct
that's right I read about that yeah and
I mean Google they move when the
presidential election came up his block
of support in the greater um Daytona
area right shifted there was agriculture
leaders in there the orange growers I
believe yeah yeah and then when you and
then one of them was a guy named Greg
stuby who went to law school with who's
a congressman who had fallen off a
ladder and hurt himself and you know he
said that Trump called him personally
uh to see how he was doing and that
DeSantis is I think fundraiser called
him to ask him for the endorsement so he
was can you go back to that can you go
back to that so it's so that means the
Santa's also a former Congressman
doesn't have the support of the majority
of the home state delegation with 12 out
of 20 House Republicans from Florida
back then
supported him I don't think it's eight
can you click on him I think it's of the
13. I could be wrong but I think as of
the 13 that have zoom in a little bit
there's only one that has actually
supported him who actually worked for
him
the state's two GOP Senators Rubio and
have not endorsed in the primary go a
little lower
okay so that's right there if you
that's not going to tell you what it is
but also Rubio and Scott have both been
aligned with Trump since 2016 I mean in
terms of publicly I don't know about
privacy yeah I got a question for you
Graham did you have a question for the
mayor Tom yeah I did you know it's very
interesting to hear you talk about
um your relationship with the sanus yeah
what happened in the gubernatorial
election gave great hope to Republicans
all across the United States a major U.S
city
Miami-Dade voted Republican that was a
big thing yeah and I'm gonna I'm not
trying to Corner you I'm asking you no
honest political analytic question did
you deliver Miami-Dade as this promise
of hope to conservatives all across
America who are seeing Republicans voted
you know Republicans carried the day and
the independence came along and oh my
goodness Miami-Dade board Republican or
did he do the work to make that happen
because it doesn't sound like that you
guys for the sake of the good report
over life
came together in a huddle and did it so
I'll give you a very simple answer very
straightforward answer so I was elected
so with the phenomenon you're describing
I'm gonna I'm gonna dig into it a little
bit more right so the phenomenon you're
describing is in 2016 Miami-Dade County
went plus 30 for Hillary against Trump
like Plus 30.
I was elected in 17 by 85 percent
and I obviously implemented a series of
policies reducing taxes low crime uh
rapid uh growth job growth right and
then in 21 I get reelected by 80 percent
and in 22 we move it from a plus 30 for
the Dems in uh in in 16 to a plus 10 for
republicans in 22. that is a 40-point
swing okay now
how can I how can I make the case that
that was me and not the governor okay
how do I make that case well look at
Jacksonville
Jacksonville is the governor's
congressional district he supported a
mayoral Kennedy the prior mayor won
which is Lenny Curry by 25 points
Republican one by 25 points the current
governor
um endorses uh the a republican in that
race against a Democrat the Democrat won
the mayor's Race by Four Points so it's
a negative
[Music]
what year was that was that this was uh
just a few months ago right here there
you go boom there this was one year
after the sweep right after this Victory
you go back four years so it's almost
the same amount of time and you go back
four years Lenny Curry wins by 25 points
he's the mayor four years ago right you
go four years later
and a Democrat wins by four points
that's a 20 you know nine point swing uh
in favor of a Democrat with the
governor's support in his home
congressional district so as far as if I
may it sounds like we're piling on wrong
that's not right that's not what it is
you asked me specific questions so I
wanted to answer it specifically that's
not what I'm saying I thought that Miami
was a great hope to the conservative
Republicans across the country that a
big city can follow a leader with the
right policies and get its head around
it and it is and that's part of my my
platform for President right which is to
say look there are at least three
discrete groups that if if Republicans
want to win the 2024 election and Beyond
when Congress when the Senate and went
generationally I think there are three
you know Mega opportunities if you will
right one is Hispanics okay Hispanics
are 20 of the population of America 60
million people okay
the last two elections we can debate who
won the election right but the last two
elections were decided by seventy
thousand and forty thousand votes
collectively right in all these little
pockets these mini States you know it
comes down to like 250 something crazy
like that although the key votes that
flip the electoral votes correct got it
exactly so the key discrepancies that
flip the electoral votes were seventy
thousand forty thousand you're talking
about a 60 million person uh population
right in Hispanics which according to
the last poll I saw which was not even a
week ago
um 20 undecided
20 undecided so do the math on that
right in terms of opportunity then you
look at young voters right voters that
are 30 or younger this is going to drive
this is gonna this is gonna make the
hairs on the back here next stand up
buying one by 26 points
an 80 year old guy who does not project
Vigor strength uh youthfulness right all
this stuff is winning young voters by 26
points right there that's why by the way
he's you know trying to do debt
forgiveness and all that stuff College
stuff and trying to win the young vote I
think that's one that my candidacy can
win last question this is our just one
of the Highlight yeah if I made time
look I'm a Miami guy born raised in
Miami I was at that 2017 announcement in
Wynwood when your dad introduced you
you're literally the first
political figure public figure that I've
ever donated to like you I got a lot of
love for Miami I got a lot a lot of love
for what you're doing in Miami
um but at the same time the whole reason
that DeSantis is even in the
conversation is because he's actually
done a good job in Florida yeah right uh
Pat has
said publicly that one of the main
reasons he moved to Florida was because
of Ron's policies so ultimately my
question is sure what grade would you
give to santis as governor for the last
two terms look I don't I don't you know
I'm not like here's a political analyst
per se like to analyze uh my uh
opponents in the presidential race
um you know as Governor look I I I think
I think he did well on covid without a
doubt
um I think
um you know I think he where he
struggles a little bit is uh you know in
terms of he has decided and I think this
this goes to the whole private sector
issue right which I think is important
right when when your only experiences in
the public sector your only ability to
implement your your ideas is using the
public sector so let's look at the
Disney issue as an example right I think
we all agree all of us I presume we all
agree that you shouldn't teach sexuality
the schools should be teaching sexuality
to young kids no doubt right we all
agree on that we talk about that all the
time so 100 so you win that argument put
it in the bank move on do a deal with
Bob Iger or you say hey you know what I
mean look we all agree on this issue
Disney's backing down we're going to
make this big investment in the state
you win the the you win the ideological
issue and then you win the economic
issue instead he doubles down he says
we're going to put a prison next to
Disney we're gonna take away their tax
exam status and and it becomes it looks
like it's personal right it goes from
ideological to personal then Bob says
hey we're going to pull back a couple
billion dollars of investment thousands
of dollars of jobs and then you start to
think to yourself wait a second is
ideology more important than creating
economic prosperity in your state right
now you're starting to create conflicts
with things that are good and then when
you take that to the foreign policy and
deal making and building relationships
and friendships that becomes an issue
right are we going to put ideology over
what's best economically for for
Americans right that's the problem so so
let me let me add something to that and
Graham I really want to get your
feedback on something but I want to add
something to that with you so
and I'm not going to pick on them either
I'm just trying to be straightforward no
no so so here's here's as a voter okay
as a voter I look at things in a couple
different ways so one I look at a
candidate and I say uh if I have who
would I want to have dinner with okay
I'd have an incredible time having
dinner with you bro I mean if we have
dinner whatever you want our friends
Sports yeah we just we'd have a blast
right because you know the the vibe like
if you and I were in the military back
in the days you know we would have had a
great time reading books
and drinking water and doing all that we
would have a great time you're that's an
important test for politics but I think
you're one million percent right but
that is an element of mine that I look
at okay
so you know then you look at the other
part can the guy get up and give
arguments of substance okay can he sell
is he willing to make himself relevant
on a daily basis on stories you know
where is he Atwood rating you know some
guys will say well you're not even
polling top six right now are you even
going to make the stage are you going to
get on there right and then well the
argument could come back and say well
Trump also 2000 didn't get on there and
he was this and he wasn't looking he's
now president okay fine so that's the
other thing that you're gonna have to
make the argument to three I think
that's fair three would be uh how uh how
good is he in
issues like you remember when you know
who was the governor of Texas back in
the days Rick Perry yeah you know the
three you know
that thinking okay so by the way you're
gonna have those moments of course 100
yeah not once not twice it's gonna
happen and that's gonna force you to go
back and do your research you had one
with Hugh Hewitt I think or whatever it
was that's gonna happen 100 it happened
to Trump it's happened to Biden it's
happening it's happened on the sentence
how you recover from that right then I
call 2023 the year of Investigations
right I said everybody and their mothers
is going to get investigated myself
included yeah so so so Trump yesterday
not to I keep saying tweeted at all we
can't even say tweeted it out whatever
the truth social is yeah he says I think
I need one more indictment to have my uh
candidacy last year or something like
that right sealed up right which is like
the indictment that he says I don't know
something like that yours comes out what
a world map yeah so here's a news Nation
what I'll just read and you know you
respond to the way Miami mayor Suarez
defends a 500 000 Auto donation receipt
by the Super PAC supporting the
Republican Presidential bid despite an
FEC he regrets I have no reason to
believe that any of the contributions
received by The Entity are not the
United States either citizens or
residents yeah the campaign Legal Center
finds a complaint uh claiming that a
passion Force llcu business allegedly
linked to China was used to hide the
true contributions to the superback SOS
America the complaint suggests a
potential violation of rules prohibiting
you know foreign
that already got cleared up in like less
than 48 hours I totally get it but all
I'm saying like you know this kind of
stuff is going to come at you for sure
and a million miles and I feel like as
as a voter I'm watching to see if I like
you check yup I'm watching if you can
make it on the stage the Forty thousand
almost thirteen forty you got to bust
your ass for that one shake the hands
can he really go deep in issues he's got
to have a good research team keep all
that stuff and how is it going to attack
you know respond back when they attack
them with different claims like this and
how's it going to handle us so what do
you say to all of those things as well
as the story I think you've identified
the four pillars of how you create a
successful candidacy so I think you're
you're you're spot on and and I love it
because I was actually listening to the
Rogan podcast uh before I came up and
and you always go back to what's
quintessential in politics which is how
do you sort of Market yourself right how
do you how do you how do you check these
boxes if you will
um
and by the way I'm not going to sit here
and tell you there's no learning curve
there has definitely been a learning
curve and and there will continue to be
a learning curve for me right
and I'll tell you uh
I mean we could talk about that for a
while right like the whole learning
curve process of this right but but
again going back to it look uh getting
the on the debate stage we are
feverishly working to get there
um being a debater and being able to
articulate
um you know sort of an argument and
being able to be inspiring and have a
vision and have a track record of
success we think I think I check all
those boxes I'm the only public official
that I know that has a podcast right
that sort of was uh different in that
sense and and revolutionary we created
Venture Miami which was in an arm of our
government specifically to help people
on board as companies to Miami when you
look at by the way the comparison
between Miami's growth and the state's
growth man we grew 14 last year
let's take her three okay that's more
than four to one the year before that 12
percent
you know what I mean our homicide rate
by the way Governors don't you know deal
with Urban Crime I do right as a mayor
so our homicide rate and by the way 85
of Americans live in American cities 91
of the GDP produced by this country is
by people who live in American towns and
cities 91 percent
last year we had a per capita homicide
rate of a low of 1964 last year okay
this year were 37 below last year's
number okay Chicago which has had
um I think 11 years in a row the murder
capital of America had 700 homicides
last year and we're different we're
smaller City Miami's the smaller City in
Chicago I want to context likes to
people say oh no you know whatever
we are uh we have 17.
year to date by the way remember the
Cocaine Cowboy years in the 1980s we
used to have 300 so just to give context
there and if we were to end the year how
we the pace that we're on right now we
would be the seventh because you gotta
compare apples to apples we'd be the
seven safest safest city per capita
in America
of population over 400 000.
so I mean look and in terms of like
dealing with these things that you were
saying like the passion fruit thing it
not already got cleared up within less
than 24 hours what happens with the
press and look we're all victims of it
every single candidate's a victim of it
is the Press shoots first and they ask
questions later because they know that
you can't sue them you can't sue them
for defamation because the public
official there's a almost impossible
standard of malice you have to prove
Mata they were malicious
right no there's a complaint we just
we're just reporting on the complaint
they don't wait like a reasonable person
before you know wait like okay somebody
put on anybody can put another complaint
anybody can sue anybody in this day and
age let's see how this plays out a
little bit before we report it no they
don't know they just put it out and then
two days later turns out it's an
american guy whose name is Ivan Soto
Wright who has a company called moonpay
very well-known company who just
attracted the CEO from Time Magazine and
the guys you know company you know they
have a similar name as the one that
supposedly is Chinese connections or
whatever you have a million dollars to a
political committee or PAC or whatever
so it's a non-story but instead of
waiting for the facts to come out they
don't they shoot first and then they
bloody you up and then of course you
have to deal with the concept of it so
so that's a uh I'm glad you're saying
that when I when I think about the
scientist the one area I think about the
scientists that I think he can do laps
around everybody and I formerly believe
this
I think the scientist's strength is
incredible with policies
incredible with policies I think he's
been in it for so long military Congress
Governor first second now here's the
here's the thing on a golf score if
you're marrying somebody you can have 20
different things on things you're
looking for to marry right
you know you could say oh my God you
know what I love about her what she was
valedictorian 4.6 GP in high school and
graduated college with a 4.0 gpn that
does that make her a great wife not
necessarily it just means she's
brilliant okay so in in the area of
policies I do believe
he can sit with anybody when we spent
three hours with the guy all he talked
about for three hours was honestly it
was only policies and you're just
sitting there you're like so teachers
union I'm like okay policy policy policy
policy policy policy America is not 90
policy America is 10 policy ninety
percent is the rest right Personality
yeah so I think I think you know Graham
question for you so you're a guy super
successful young guy 33 years old April
baby you just turned 33 three months ago
right you've done very well for yourself
you started real estate at 18 years old
you sold 130 million dollars a real
estate you got a beautiful life you
moved out of California you moved to
Nevada you lived in Nevada you've made
videos before I think you made one a
couple years ago yeah April fools you
know you're moving back to California
all that stuff I I saw that video like a
year ago or something so so for you I
got a couple questions for you because I
think your opinion matters a lot all of
us at this table are above 40. okay
you're the only one that's 33 years old
so you're closer to the 20 crowd and
you're right in the middle you're a very
very important voter okay because you're
also a business guy who's got influence
people actually listen to what you have
to say it's not easy to create a
business Channel with four or five
million subscribers okay it's easy to
create it if it's spoof pranks all that
stuff very hard to build a business
channel four or five million subscribers
because that audience it's not that
interesting to everybody they want to be
laughing they want to be doing that
stuff so you obviously know what you're
doing what's important to you
at this age when you're looking at who
you want as a president one will say
whether they know where you lean
politically left and right I don't think
you ever talk about where you lean
politically but I think for a guy that's
a street guy guy like me whose job is to
read people I would say you vote right
you don't have to answer that but I'm
just telling you for a guy like me if
you if you escape California and you go
to Nevada you're not fully right but
you're right enough if you will maybe
further right you would have moved to
Texas or Florida but you went to Nevada
to be kind of Mark Wahlberg right which
is kind of like you know what I'm saying
perhaps like Santa right Hollywood so so
what's important to you why did you
leave California and what are you
looking for as a businessman for your
next president well I definitely think
well first of all when I made that video
leaving California for Las Vegas uh
someone from the business administration
of Las Vegas reached out to me and I
remember Googling them and thinking oh
why is this person emailing me this is
crazy that this person at this stasher
would reach out to me and they sent me
an email they said hey I want to let you
know we all in our office saw your video
we really enjoyed it if there's anything
we could help you with please reach out
we're here thank you so much but it's
never I would never have imagined that
they would have been appreciative of me
moving into Las Vegas bringing you know
what I have to offer there would never
happen in California but for me
California it just I didn't feel like it
was worth it to stay uh when covet
happened and all of a sudden I was
working from home I thought why do I
need to be here even though I've spent
my entire life there and I like it there
but I just saw it going downhill and
just visiting Vegas and seeing how nice
it was and I thought this is only four
hours away and I moved and it was such a
great decision everything there is more
affordable there's not traffic it's very
clean uh all of our neighbors by the way
are either from California or New York
you're from New York to New York yes so
a huge percentage of people came from
California and you know even walking up
and down the street they're like people
from Newport Beach San Francisco Los
Angeles San Diego
but I think for me I'm I'm really in the
middle of a lot of things where I could
be swayed either way and when it comes
to Republican or Democratic I look at
both people and I say well I like this
about these people this is about this uh
for me I think relatability is something
that's really important to me uh and I
guess it's being realistic and just just
give me policies like give me policies
for a guy like you we need more people
like you I think when we talk about hero
making machine we need young guys who
look up if a 17 year old kid is looking
up to you I'm good because we need more
17 year olds who want to grow up be
disciplined work hard you know get their
license take care of their family buy
their house live their dreams and then
sell the dream to others so they can
emulate so to me you're an ideal
candidate for a hero to 16 17 year old
that nowadays in high school people when
they grow up they want to be what they
want to be YouTubers right
but actually tell me policies at 33
years old
you've paid millions of dollars of taxes
is that a fair assessment to say you pay
millions of dollars in taxes more so
when you pay millions of dollars in
taxes when you are in the mix of
speaking you're you're creating content
you're no longer like uh low level level
you know issues it's no longer like I
just want somebody that I can trust
[__] I mean we all you know it's
it's not something that we can all say
what are actual issues that matter to
you at 33 years old successful
entrepreneur issues I would say the most
relatable to me because they don't have
kids yeah and so the one thing that
affects me the most is probably taxes
um but I would say from that perspective
lowering tax from 39.6 to 37 would be no
different than Biden saying well we'll
get rid of student loan debt because
that affects me so I think obviously I
would be enticed by something like that
but I also think realistically would
that make that big of a difference
probably not uh if they increase to
capital gains from 20 to 22 percent
probably not is something for me to
consider so in terms of policies I would
say fiscally
I would like to see some savings but
that's just me being selfish on that and
I try to look at the bigger picture and
see where's the money going and I think
that for me is a big thing of just
seeing the national debt skyrockets he's
spending Skyrocket and I see some of
these things and people are able to slip
like here's 500 million in this policy
in this huge package of trillions of
dollars let's put 200 million over here
and I think just adding the stuff up
where does the money go and so when I
see that and I see what I'm paying in
tax I have no idea where the money goes
and that for me is something that at
least I consider if you talk about what
you liked about Nevada and why you moved
there so you're staying in the positive
what didn't you like about what Newsome
did in California that caused you to
leave oh gosh I think crime and homeless
were two big issues because I grew up
and I live for quite a long time in
Santa Monica and just seeing what has
happened in that city has been awful and
I don't think there's the proper support
support system for people who are
mentally ill on the street and that's
what a lot of it is at least from my
perspective from what I've seen these
are not people who the landlord raised
their rent and now they're on the street
these are severely mentally ill people
who who oftentimes have severe drug
addiction and from what I've seen is
just not the support system there for
those people to take them off the street
so what they're doing is they're on the
street uh nothing could be done crime is
going up and especially in Venice it's
just saying that the police won't even
respond there's that one video uh
recently where people went into the
Gucci store uh in Century City and they
just ransacked the place and left and
everyone's just there on the front you
see the security guard by the way just
standing there and I get it you're not
supposed to necessarily value a Louis
Vuitton bag over someone's life if these
people are armed is that really
something you want to risk your life can
you play this clip
just play the clip if you can with
security guards
this is Century City Mall this is
Century City called the outdoor mall so
this is right by Beverly Hills I know
exactly where this is Bloomingdale's is
in here so I know where that's at yeah
so Graham can I ask you a question on
that right there and and literally I
couldn't ask uh mayor Suarez a better
question why you're saying this
so you got out of Santa Monica La you
went to Nevada yeah how much of and
we've heard this multiple times the
Homeland says the crime uh the traffic
obviously how much of these issues uh do
you put on a Gavin Newsom as the
governor I.E a DeSantis in Florida or on
the mayor which I think I believe at the
time was Garcetti and now it's Karen
bass I believe what is that relationship
like how do you personally put this on
the politician because you must have
been in rooms with buddies friends dude
I lived here my whole life is a mess are
you blaming a Garcetti the mayor are you
blaming a Newsome and then and the mayor
swore it was way in after yeah sure it
seems like Newsome takes the heat for
everything so my initial thought is
Newsome but I think you also have to put
some emphasis on the mayor as well for
sure um but I feel like Newsome gets the
clicks gets the headline so for me as
just a person who's honestly right in
the middle of a lot of things when you
see news some news some Newsome it gets
clicks and that's where my mind first
time like when you see an image of
Newsome not to like put you on the spot
like is it like hey that's my guy oh
disgusted like is there how does
emotionally do you respond to that guy
it's tough because I feel like you have
to be tougher on crime than that I mean
that that should not be happening it
shouldn't be a policy where if someone
steals something you just have to step
back there's got there's got to be
something in between risking your life
when you see his image how you feel
about that knowing a little bit
obviously left so well it looks like a
movie Ville in there knowing a little
bit about LA because I lived there uh
until moving to Dallas and then moving
here
um I can tell you that at the time there
was uh a crime base that was being
addressed and mayor Richard rodden was
working on that yeah but he was rebuffed
with support dollars from Sacramento and
and in Sacramento they were saying Hey
We're Not Gonna We're not gonna send
these support dollars to LA county and
so great Dave this was able to intervene
so the governor can handcuff mayor's
efforts if he doesn't like them but
State support what the the State dollars
that are going to going to move around
and by the way you said Nevada sent you
a nice email yeah trust me if you
liquidate a major asset within four
years of leaving California they will
also send you a nice email because
they have that law where they will if
they recapture it yeah if they think you
move to sell a company
congratulations
did you get that email from California
anything like that no no no did you get
any Love Letters from California we miss
you Graham I come back I hired uh a
great accountant great attorney uh I had
everything done exactly as it needed to
be because I didn't want to leave any
loose ends I was like whatever I need to
do to prove and show and do this
correctly the last thing I want to do if
I if I make a mistake that's coming back
on me so I hired a great great team and
I mean we made such a clean cut and how
often do you go back to California and
you're like I miss it here but then you
see the homeless guy music in the street
like I'm glad it's it's rare it might be
a few days every now and then every few
months uh just going and visiting When I
visit I mean there's certainly an aspect
to Los Angeles where I like the weather
and I like the culture and I like the
motivation and the mindset of some of
the people there it's very forward
thinking in terms of being an
entrepreneur being a business owner uh
you know pushing boundaries I I think
there's something to be said about the
motivation and the hustle of Los Angeles
that you don't get in Las Vegas mayor
Suarez how would you clean up this mess
that Graham uh forced him to leave what
would you look it's it's actually not
that difficult right um you just cannot
Implement socialist policies right so
what what what happened what have we
done in Miami that's very different from
a lot of these cities right first is we
never got into the defund police
movement never this no that was never a
thing in Miami contrary we actually
increase funding for police officers we
have more officers than we've ever had
in our history so this nonsense of
defund police never happened secondly
and you see it manifesting itself in
that video the concept of no cash bail
right where you get arrested and then
you're back on the street you don't even
have to post bail
um and you're back on the street there's
no consequence
there's no consequence to committing
crime right we live in a society of laws
there's supposed to be a consequence
when you break the law right you you go
to jail and then you have to stand for
trial et cetera et cetera when you take
away all those things because you want
to be sympathetic what you end up doing
is you have a situation where now CVS
well how many how many articles have we
seen of CVS and Walgreens and people
shuddering saying hey look the loss is
greater than the gain right so so who
gets hurt so now you're trying to you're
trying to be sympathetic to to the
person who's committing crime and what
you're ultimately doing is you're
diminishing the quality of life of every
single other citizen we have this issue
a lot with homelessness right you want
to be very Humane with the homeless
they're human beings absolutely you have
to be Humane in the treatment of
homeless but you also have to understand
that they their actions impact everybody
else and so there are things that you
know were previously legal for the
homeless to do in the city of Miami that
we changed through federal laws
and you know federal case where before
they could basically defecate and
urinate in public they called them
life-sustaining activities and they
weren't even required to go to a
bathroom if there was a bathroom within
a certain feet distance right things
that you and I couldn't do we couldn't
just go outside pull our pants down and
go to the bathroom right we'd get
arrested for indecent exposure so there
was almost like this sort of two-tiered
system and and so for us we never got
into no cash bail we never got into
defund police we increased funding for
our police officers we maintained Law
and Order when the George Floyd protest
happened net things never got out of
control in Miami because I said look
there's a line here right the line is
we're not going to let you harm people's
property and we're not going to let you
harm people and We're Not Gonna Let You
harm police officers if you try to do
any of those things we're going to
arrest you we're gonna hold you
accountable and we did and so there was
no antifa there was none of that came
here everybody to the extent that they
might have been here on day one they
were gone
um and so we had very little arrest uh
we were able to manage that very
intelligently and so and then I think
there's two other pieces right
to crime prevention we have the lowest
unemployment rate in America
full stop okay highest wage growth in
America full stop so and and these are
qualitative rankings but we're ranked
the happiest city in America and the
healthiest city in America so it turns
out if you're happy you're healthy
you're working and there's police
officers guess what you're not doing
committing violent crime or committing
crime right so it's not like a super
complex formula right it's it's sort of
basic and we've gotten away from it
because we've let these sort of
socialist ideologies
um which for me I think the biggest
danger in in the world is communism and
socialism because my parents got kicked
out of their country of birth when a
leader there said give us all your
property give us all your businesses and
don't worry we'll make everybody equal
and he did he made everybody equally
poor and equally miserable and and
thanks Fidel yeah yeah and that and you
so but by the way it's the easiest sell
in politics Graham with all that being
said when are you moving to Miami buddy
let's go man I love Vegas I love Vegas
what a diplomatic what do you think we
need to get you to a beach
so so let me let me ask this a question
about uh when we're talking about these
cities and what's going on with the
crime Gucci all this other stuff you've
seen it all over the place and the
security is kind of just kind of
standing around how much of this is you
know uh uh Sanctuary city laws how much
of this is the fact that you know you
don't do anything with them you know the
whole concept of the definition of a
sanctuary city is uh where a city defies
the federal law to say no we're not
going to follow your guidelines we're
going to follow our own guidelines you
know we're not going to do what you're
doing for example New York City the
largest city we have that's you know and
they have Sanctuary laws since spring of
last year they've had 93 000 migrants
that came to New York City just this
weekend a video was going viral can you
play that clip uh New York City if you
type in New York City sanction
um uh uh immigrants type in New York
City immigrants they're sleeping in the
uh on the outside yeah if you can find
it right there if you can make that
bigger that's awful so you know these
guys are coming in here thinking well
this is a sanctuary City it's okay if I
come here and live here 200 people are
sleeping outside because there's no
place to go mayor Adams is going around
saying hey you know we need help we need
to do this we're not going to change the
laws of being a sanctuary City but at
the same time we need funding from the
federal government so Tom are you
familiar with the whole Sanctuary City
deal so when you arrest somebody and you
fingerprint them the Police Department
is supposed to report that to the FBI
the FBI reports that to ice just purely
for documentation ice can come back and
say we want you to hold them for 48
hours and a sanctuary City can say no
we're not going to hold them we're going
to release them right the whole catch
them we're going to release them and
they're not going to have to be held
here
but mayor Adam saying we don't want to
follow federal guidelines on what it is
when people arrest them but hey Biden
can you sell us some money because we're
really having a hard time with you know
the stuff that's going on so how much of
the issues that's going on in these
cities you think is caused by Sanctuary
city laws either one of you
I I have my opinion on it as an informed
voter looking in I think Sanctuary city
is ridiculous I think basically what it
was is a hidden it was it's it's
basically a hidden word it's a word and
we have to look at what's behind the
word what's behind the word is socialist
policies and lacks immigration and so is
it a good thing to check people at the
border I mean the Statue of Liberty says
give us retired reporter huddle masses
yearning to breathe free come here we
all come from somewhere American is a
citizen American is in a race it's an
idea and a citizen we all come from
somewhere so the immigration that comes
here that's what we're all about you
know and you're coming and you're coming
here because some because somewhere else
I'm doing a podcast I'll call you
afterwards
for Joe we're so good
guy right here yeah I know
[Laughter]
my man I got somebody wants to say hello
to you I don't know if you recognize
this guy mayor of Miami how you doing
man how's it going good to see you
brother you good hey man what are we
doing a cafe though bro let's go
whenever you want my brother
[Laughter]
but you got to be a partner you got to
be a partner with me on that if we do
that
[Music]
my wife bro my wife was 16 years will
not be cool with that oh my goodness you
guys have editing questions
[Music]
Mercy
sorry about that so from campaigning to
clubbing in six seconds yeah see to see
by the way I took the brunt of that joke
that was on me the underage uh situation
none of you guys have not nothing to do
with it no I I think I think the
sanctuary city laws is basically it's a
cloak and what the voters don't
understand is that they're being used
they're being manipulated and what it is
is you're bringing unchecked a
immigration in under the guise if you're
going to be inspecting it and then you
have mayors of cities that are basically
trying to look good and and you draw a
clear line to ID free voting okay go
ahead no I'm I was going to go to you
yeah so I I just say so to me this is
there's two issues here right one issue
is lawlessness right like what you're
seeing in that Gucci video is
lawlessness right this it's pervaded uh
Los Angeles San Francisco like the sense
that the law just doesn't apply why you
could just go into a supermarket and you
see people like scooping stuff into a
garbage can right that's why it's all
locked up by the way right and now it's
everything is locked so it's either
locked up or they or they close the
place so then nobody gets it so that's
per number one number two the border is
a disaster
it's a disaster right and and it is a
human trafficking disaster and it is a
and it is a fentanyl disaster okay so
let me give you some insight into that I
would start talking to one of the
executive producers of sound of freedom
and he was telling me that
um human trafficking is becoming bigger
business for the cartels than drugs and
guns nope that's crazy okay that is
crazy and that's all happening at the
southern border right and then fentanyl
is killing 80 to 90 000 Americans right
which is the equivalent of a 747
crashing every day so think about this
right we had this National tragedy when
these five people were in the
submersible and we're trying to figure
out right so imagine if every day a
plane is crashing every day you would
stop everything you're doing you would
declare a national emergency and you
would dedicate whatever resources you
need to solve that problem and we're not
doing it and now you have as as Pat said
you have a mayor a Democrat mayor saying
hey man I'm overwhelmed I need help
right
um then don't be a sanctuary City well
if you're over there you want the
federal government to help you don't be
essentially part of it that's definitely
part but I think I think I think the
second part is we've got to be realistic
about the border which is a mess yeah
and and it has to be solved right and
and and look in Miami-Dade County just
to give you a sense
we had I think last year 14
000 undocumented illegal immigrants in
our in our County that were children for
the public school system that's the
equivalent of seven
2 000 children school that's
that's a strain on the system so what
happens in a city or in a community or
in a county is this causes a massive
strain on resources
um and so that that's another issue that
that mayor's got to deal with we got 500
Sanctuary cities in America 500 we've
got 11 Sanctuary states in America
States we got DC's in sanctuary city
right and number one in crime uh you can
keep going on and on with all these
stats of what's going on in the these
different in DC do you know in DC when
you pull somebody over if you ask them
for their ideas considered racial
profiling
if you pull somebody over and you ask
them for ID they can say that's racial
profiling so there's a part of DC
Chicago's got similar laws like that as
well but I can't ask somebody for say
what should in Florida if somebody did
what they did to that Gucci store what
what's going to happen to those guys
that did what they did at the Gucci look
there was a video and I I you know I
don't want to make light of this because
unfortunately the guy died are you
talking about the Victoria's Secret yes
yeah it was this was like three blocks a
week ago like a guy walks into a
Victoria's Secret in one of these malls
similar Mall Lincoln Road Lincoln Road
most famous mall I mean puts a knife to
the to to you know a mother and a
daughter mother daughter tonight and
it's up there and he was shot and killed
yeah right here he was shot and killed
by Miami PD I mean I'm sorry Miami Beach
people yeah I should correct that Miami
Beach PD
um so it's just a different I mean look
at the different response you've got uh
you know people running out of the other
store right with a bunch of goods in
this case you've got
you know three police officers that are
here he backs out now because he sees
that the lady has a knife
um boom so he backs away
um you know to give the guy space to
make sure that he doesn't do something
crazy and ultimately it ends in um in in
the police involved shooting where the
guy's killed so I mean and here's the
question I look I don't I didn't see I
don't know if he's black white asian
Puerto Rican it doesn't matter it's
their understanding you're holding a
knife holding a woman hostage if you're
gonna kill a woman it's not racist for
the cops to shoot you is it something
else which is important very important
it's important p i want you to hear this
it's important to be pro-police okay why
first of all it never used to be
controversial in America to be pro-law
enforcement it never used to be a
controversial political Republican
Democrat not according to NWA though but
that's a side issue yeah true fair point
um for everybody
um but but I think you know law
enforcement I mean these people now are
making very little money they're hard
it's hard to recruit them Across America
and I can tell you of being president of
the U.S Conference of Mayors president
of all the city's America I see here
from City to City
and they have the high scrutiny and the
highest risk so they're risking their
life but they're also risking that if
that guy we're we're slow you know we're
reviewing what he did you know sort of
the way we review NFL players to see if
they stepped out of bounds right like
instant replay and yet the difference is
you don't get to go to the next play
right if you make a mistake you go to
jail right so now you're risking your
life on the one hand you're risking your
freedom on the other hand and you're not
getting paid it's not like you're
getting paid like a NFL player right to
take that kind of risk so we're really
asking of our officers a lot and I think
part of what you see there culturally is
a community that's pro-law enforcement
versus a community that may not be so
pro-law enforcement and officers who say
hey man I'm not going to take certain
risks because I don't want to be put out
on Front Street by public officials that
are not going to back me uh and I've
been you know very pro-law enforcement
um you know I was a victim of a home
invasion robbery when I was a kid you
had officers respond I was a mayor at
the time they made a human chain they
didn't know if the perpetrators were in
the house I mean they risked their lives
and and I feel incredibly indebted to
them uh and grateful for for the men and
women who serve our cities as a lot as a
citizen what do you think should happen
to those guys that Gucci
oh I I don't know I mean obviously
there's got to be some action taken
um I don't have a good solution to that
I mean I I think maybe the security
should be stepping it up a little bit to
prevent but I also think it's got to be
more of a deterrent because I think a
lot of these crimes and Petty crimes I
think the crime is different between
holding a knife to someone's neck for
sure and grabbing a bag and running out
of the store
um but I think there needs to be more of
a deterrent uh from my assumption it
seems like the reason a lot of this
crime happens is because there's not
enough of a deterrent to say I shouldn't
do this because the consequences are so
high I think Pat's question is actually
super important I think I think your
response is super important because
not to even be political I think it's
very important how you answer this
because if you ask me and my buddies if
with Adrian whatever and like hey what
do you guys think not political just
like yeah you take that guy out walk me
through the mindset of buddies friends
of yours in LA because there must be a
Groundswell of people to be like no they
can't they can't hold these guys
accountable walk me through your dinner
with friends I can't imagine in L.A what
they're thinking or like no it's racism
walk me through that mindset I think
generally it has to be a deterrent I
from my perspective I just think okay if
the consequence of that is let's just
say a hundred years in prison people
would think twice about that so where do
you find the balance between this is an
appropriate punishment for that to deter
that from happening so for me yeah look
here's here's how this works
the part that's confusing is they'll
come out and they'll say that is such
bad behavior look what they did they
should have never killed this person all
they were doing is doing this what's
wrong with that do you know how bad it
is to be poor and you know how this is
the economical problem that we're having
and there's like dude the guy was
robbing somebody right so if we cannot
identify what's a bad guy if we don't
know how to identify what's about I want
you to watch this clip this is Kroger's
I don't know if you guys seen this or
not a grandma
87 year old lady is walking out at
Kroger's Watch What Happens a man tries
to take her purse then watch what takes
place go ahead and play this clip okay
if you can fast forward a little bit
the man in the blue jacket out of the
store and down to the ground I'm hearing
her voice screaming and her being scared
I just knew I had to do this
87 year old this guy snatched
so so I want you to see this here this
is the point of this thing they end up
giving that guy an award a black man
protects a white 87 year old woman from
being robbed from another white man okay
so so what's what's the what's the moral
of this story to me this is hero making
machine okay you're protecting my
grandma I like it yesterday a video went
viral of these two Indians at a store I
don't know if you saw this one here yeah
so can you go to the other one this
video at the store where these this this
guy goes in there
and he's just just press play and we'll
fast forward this as well plus we're not
going to watch a whole thing these guys
are secrets
it's a complete different story in the
other situation
the black guy is protecting an older
white lady here this has got nothing to
do with color
so he's taking all this stuff in look at
this
and then fast forward a little bit he
tries to show he's got a knife right
there watch that and then all of a
sudden look like he's trying to say if
you do anything I'll take it fast
forward fast forward fast forward a
little more a little more a little more
a little more a little more keep going a
little bit more it's about to happen and
then I'll write there right so right
leave it right there don't do that Watch
What Happens right there sure it came
with a phone that's a broom by the way
okay and they just you know now beating
his ass okay so pause it now we don't
need to sit here and get high off of
this guy getting his ass beat the the
moral of the story here is the deterrent
story you're talking about I have to
know there's a punishment if I go out
there and do that if I don't think there
is what's going to stop me from stealing
I'm gonna keep doing it because
nothing's gonna happen to me and there's
a there's an additional component which
is you you start to see sort of what you
kind of look at like kind of like
vigilante justice right people taking
the matters into their own hands which
subjects them to Danger right because if
they don't feel like something's going
to be done if there's just this it just
becomes more lawlessness right like this
is anarchy right people trying to steal
from you you defending yourself I mean
it's literally Anarchy right and and one
of the let me just say two quick points
one of the biggest fallacies on this
sort of defund police movement right
look obviously when horrific things
happen you know it creates a lot of
emotion but when you go into inner
cities in a city like mine or in any
City I guarantee you it's the same in
Chicago New York uh La Washington
they're all the same if you go to an
inner city they're not going to tell you
we want to see less police officers
they're going to tell you the opposite
they're going to tell you we don't see
as many police officers as some of the
wealthy areas so it is the exact
opposite phenomenon and then I'll tell
you another thing another stat that blew
my mind as a mayor whatever there's
officer involved misconduct we're the
first ones I get to call right from the
Press reaction blah blah blah I hadn't
gotten a call on that and I knock on
wood I'm not sure if this is wood but I
knock on wood right hoping that I don't
get the call
for a while
and so I I reached out to my chief and
said hey chief let me ask you a question
how many officer involved complaints did
we have last year officer about
complaints right complaints total
take a guess we have 1400 officers how
many officers involved complaints we had
237 okay so I said my the next logical
question is what do you compare that
number to right how many calls for
service how many times do our citizens
call our officers needing their service
or they interact or the customer because
you're you're into marketing customer
service right so how many times do R 911
calls get made where our officers are
being asked to get involved in a
situation
330 000.
so out of 330 000 citizen interactions
calls for service 237 complaints
not sustained complaints not like hey
237 times that they made a mistake right
it's 237 overall complaints of which
maybe half of them are sustained maybe
less I don't know I don't know what the
actual rate was and I got I got to look
into that so that's point one percent
yeah I mean it's it's nothing so that
story isn't getting told the story of
this phenomenal customer service if you
had a call center if you had a call
center and and your call center had 330
000 interactions and only 230 people
complained about those 300 you would be
like this is incredible service
99.9 99.9 how do you how do you beat
that right and so that story isn't
getting told and I've asked those for
those statistics in other cities and
it's it's equivalent uh to ours let me
let me ask a question about Miami so
because you know the good comes with the
bad right so when you're winning yeah
it's great you got to brag about it when
you're you gotta hit you got to talk
about it as well article comes out from
um
yeah so Wall Street Journal comes up
with an article talks about how Miami
sees its first population drop in
decades Miami's facing his first
population losses over a multi-year
period since uh at least 1970 with
Miami-Dade losing 79 000 uh 535 people
through net migration to other parts of
Florida other states between 2020 and
2022 as per Brookings institution
analysis surging home prices up 53
percent June 2020 on a chronic shortage
of affordable rental housing has
contributed to the population drop
miami-dade's unemployment rate is below
the national average but the labor
market lags behind the rest of Florida
with the total number of employed people
slightly below 2019 levels in May the
city attracts new businesses with 127
000 businesses and applications made in
2022 but many firms open small or
satellite offices employing few people
While others focus on cryptocurrencies
which have experienced a market downturn
what's your response to this WSU article
well there's a lot to unpack there um
it's funny how you hear her the phrase
there's Liars there's liars and then
there's statisticians
so
um there's so much to unpack on that
like it's funny how they there was a
part where you were reading about the
unemployment they were comparing it to
2019. it's like it was like one it's
like 1.8 now and it was 1.6 then so it's
like it's crazy to say yeah it's it's
slightly up but it's up to like
ridiculously historically low uh levels
so there's two things one is is hard for
people to understand which is that I'm
the mayor of the city of Miami which is
different from Miami-Dade County so
that's that's a statistic about
Miami-Dade County versus the city of
Miami so just to give you a sense on on
our numbers right we grew 14 last year
so what is that number constitute that
is the the value of all the properties
that's our what do we call our tax base
so that is
um property value appreciation
plus new construction combined right
that's the total value the way you
calculate those what have you built new
and what is the appreciation of we're
told right that's basically the total so
it's hard for me to believe
that in a city where you grew 14 through
a combination of value appreciation and
new construction the population for that
city has gone down so there's a bit of
an incongruity there
um but the second piece is
um that look you you have a situation
where growth or not growth is really a
function of supply and demand right so
why
um why do people leave places like
California why uh uh you know Illinois
New York California why well first first
phenomenon is assault deduction going
away so an assault deduction went away
you're talking about having to pay an
additional 13 yeah 0.3
13.3 he knows to the decimal every
little Point thirteen point three
percent more in federal income taxes
than you did before and that's fair
because why should the federal
government and this was you know thanks
to you know Donald Trump and Paul Ryan
and the tax law that they passed why
should the federal government subsidize
a state like New York that has less
people than Florida but twice the budget
why right it shouldn't and so now it's
fair unfortunately that phases out by
the way but now it's fair but what
happened is you had a flood of people a
flood of people from those those cities
coming to Miami now we have one thing
that we have that New York doesn't have
or San Francisco doesn't have we have
the ability to grow
we have the ability to grow 10x
so the Delta between what's built right
now and what can be built we have a
form-based code which is like sort of
invisible boxes on top of buildings the
Delta between what's built and what can
be built is a ten to one multiple but it
takes time right I mean it's not I wish
I could say 30 000 units go right done
right it takes time you you for Supply
to meet demand takes time it's a three
year Horizon right when you consider you
got to get you know draw plans you got
to go to permitting you got to build a
thing it's a year and a half to two
years right that takes time so the
phenomenon happened quick and we're
building a significant amount of units
uh I think we have 35 000 units in our
residential pipeline that's like a 20
increase in our in our housing stock
um that will get built in the next two
to three years
um we did 50 million in affordable
housing that we got a 20 to one leverage
rate so for every dollar we put in the
private sector put in another 20. it was
actually 1.1 billion for 50 million
dollars of investment 3 500 units at all
the different income levels so I
challenge any city in America America or
any government or any institution to get
a 20 leverage rate on their dollar
um so we're efficient in terms of how we
spend our money and what we get for that
expenditure that'll probably come down
with higher interest rates right the
rates are higher so you're not going to
get as much leverage
um and that's fine but we've got on the
57 million that we're going to spend and
we're doing everything we can but I
don't believe that government is the one
that solves these problems I think
government oftentimes makes the problem
worse so for example
um you look at areas that have
um rent controls right so you think oh
just put in rent controls that's that
solves everything no it doesn't because
what it does is maybe it helps the
people who are currently in stock right
but you create two problems and they're
long-term problems problem number one is
as you know you can't recapitalize a
building and a bank will lend you the
money if they don't think they're going
to get an Roi right so what happens is
you end up creating slums over time
because you cannot
recap those buildings and that's what's
happening in New York you have ghost
buildings you have buildings where
there's nobody in the building because
the building has decayed Beyond its its
useful life and and you can't recap the
building because you can't you can't
increase rent it's a very important
Point you're making time both of you
guys can comment on this you're in real
estate Tom you hear what he's saying
about this what are your thoughts on
those comments well first of all I I
agree with part of it and I think a
distinction needs to be made especially
in Florida where
um uh Suarez and Cava have to be in
Partnership right because she's the
mayor of the county greater Miami-Dade
County and that has to be a partnership
number one and but number two rent
controls you know you were about to
continue and I'm sure you're about to
say key money where the landlords
artificially inflate rent you know by
implementing key money so here's your
rent and everything like this but I need
three thousand dollars upfront key money
and what that is is 500 bucks a month
prepaid in there to artificially make it
but I I do think to be fair
um there's you know
part of the part of the election is
building up donor bases sure and
developers are a lot of part of the
donor bases so I think that Mayors can
because you've got influence over the
donors because the donors want to have
influence on who's elected mayor is that
fair that's fair and so there I think
there can be more of a partnership on
affordable housing which also gets tied
to transit systems because you're not
going to put affordable down housing
down in South Beach right but there are
people fish there but there are jobs and
opportunities down there where we need
labor for you actually don't wish so no
I know I live in South Beach so I think
you have to have you know look you know
this is all part of urban planning and
Partnerships it goes hey we're going to
have the affordable housing we're going
to enable this and we're going to have
the transit system so these people can
easily get back and forth to where the
jobs are but but this isn't I mean look
this is a lot easier than people make it
out to be this is not that complex right
these are pretty simple formulas
mathematics right in terms of the fact
that for example to your point we uh
there's a building that's going up right
now on the river in Miami I think it's
the Austin Martin building right it's an
acre it sold the dirt sold for 125
million dollars
so you cannot spec out an affordable
housing building on 125 million dollar
an acre piece of land right it just
doesn't spec out you had uh the the
Genting property that's a 15 acre
property I think uh the the you know the
deal fell through but it was a billion
two raw land
right and that was a discount right that
was a little less than 100 million
dollars an acre it's a discount even
though it's home right so you cannot
build affordable housing on that you've
got to Leverage
County and City assets this is where the
partnership you were describing is
important you have to leverage those
assets and then you have to subsidize
right and and at some level and then
what I like what we do is we hand it
over to the private sector and they
manage it within certain income
restrictions right at their risk because
they're much better at managing it than
we are uh it's not our competency so in
New York you saw those tenement housings
houses you know housing projects over
years and and basically people were
living in in basically in slums right so
you you get much better product it's
built in a way that people can live in
with pride they have amenities in these
buildings uh and that's part of the
reason why I believe like in overtime we
did 60 million dollars of affordable
housing in Overtown and that's why I
believe the crime has gone down
significantly because people are indoors
they're not hanging out outside they're
they're they they have um you know a TV
Center they have a gym they have you
know they have a a plaza where they can
hang out they can do everything indoors
and uh and they live in Pride can I ask
you a question on that
oh yeah in terms of rent control the one
flaw that you did bring up is that it's
not based on income it really benefits
the people who get in early and then
don't move at all which oftentimes types
of Housing and I've seen so many tenants
make hundreds of thousands of dollars a
year who just happened to get in early
rent the same place from 1995. their
rent is maybe a thousand dollars a month
they'll make 300 Grand and they don't
want to leave because why would I give
this off it's like a pension exactly but
I had an instance in Santa Monica where
a condo owner rented out to what was
called a protected tenant she had been
there for 40 something years and I think
over the age of 65 you can't kick her
out for any reason this lady was making
a few hundred thousand dollars a year
and her rent was capped at like 500 a
month for a condo in Santa Monica the
owner inherited it and tried to get her
out because they wanted to sell it could
not sell it no one wanted to touch it
because the HOA and property taxes were
worth 3 times what the tenant was paying
in rent right and she was a very healthy
60 something year old that's government
yoga on the beach every day and she had
she's happy there they gave her hundreds
of thousands to move out doesn't want to
do it yeah so that kind of validates the
point but it benefits people who get in
early stay and it's not really based up
but it ties up units yeah so let me let
me ask this question when it comes on to
crypto Tom what was the the number you
said about percentage of Republicans how
they feel about crypto
yeah there is a in all the polling you
know you have issues pulling and
starting we're starting to starting to
rain down on us as we get closer and
closer to the debate stage and 46 of
core Republicans and they were looking
at broad-based so not City Base but
broad-based sure
um did you know we're skeptical of
crypto and only when they give them a
five-point scale of what on whether you
feel positively about something very
positive positive neutral negative
negative so it's standard Leica five
point scale only six percent of them
said they felt positive about crypto and
they had skepticism about it and saw
risk in it so that's so that's that's an
issue for you because in the name of
Entrepreneurship you're also bringing
that sector I regard crypto as sort of a
sector of a larger entrepreneurial
ecosystem that comes with it every
sector has got its risk and this happens
to be tied to financial services but you
have a lot of Voters in there they're
like I'm not sure about this which also
can kind of attached to you a little bit
yeah look I think that's a fair point
um for me the way I look at it is it's
an ecosystem play as you sort of stated
it right which is we are a number one in
the nation in wage growth right we've
created a ton of high-paying jobs and
part of that is because we've leaned
into generational Technologies right we
haven't been afraid of those
generational Technologies like you said
there are risks involved I often cite
the example of Netscape and Napster
right everybody remembers Netscape and
app store they're no longer with us
right their companies did not succeed
but what they created changed the world
right
um you know you obviously have Spotify
Apple music Etc and then you have Google
um
et cetera so the initial Technologies
don't often or the initial companies
don't often succeed but the technology
changes the world I think with crypto
part of the problem is our elected
officials don't understand it many of
them a b they haven't and this is this
is I think a failure of the Biden
Administration they have not created
rules
uh to allow people to play on an equal
footing and to be domestic companies as
opposed to Offshore companies right and
so we've seen what's happened the sort
of disaster there not having any rules
related to custody assets which is what
you know banking rules are right sort of
basic rules doesn't matter whether it's
a cryptocurrency or otherwise it's an
asset you've got to have rules on how
you custody that asset what you can do
with those customer assets
um you know no no rules as to whether
some things are regulated by uh by the
Commodities uh uh uh exchange or whether
they're regulated by the SEC right I
mean so so you have a lot of vagueness
in terms of the products that you create
what class does this live in exactly and
so you have not created an inviting uh
environment you're now starting to see
Republican Congress uh men Amer which is
the majority
um Whip and others uh be very Pro crypto
and even Democrats are becoming more
pro-crypto now because I think they
realize how many people are have crypto
accounts so I don't know how old that
particular poll is that you're talking
about it's it's coming right now it's
you were saying it's going to come out
now no it's it's it's coming in the last
three days as these issues can I ask you
a question I can't put you on the debate
stage yeah of course mayor Suarez of
course mayor Suarez you're paid in
crypto so obviously you have some
affinity and you've tried to attract it
to your city yeah what would you say the
American voter that is still skeptical
about it
I would say that um you know things like
artificial intelligence things like
cryptocurrencies uh things like Quantum
Computing are going to redefine the
future if I can find a way to prevent my
child from being a lot of time on this
thing then maybe we can have a different
conversation but the truth is that we
can stick our head in the sand and
pretend like it doesn't exist it's not
going to benefit our children and I'm
running for president because I want to
create prosperity for the maximum number
of Americans and the only way to do that
is not to be afraid of the future but to
lean into the future here's here's what
by the great answer here's what I would
say to you I think crypto Community is a
political party I don't know how big it
is but it is a political party and
whoever wins it sometimes
you know mayor Giuliani ran for
president 2004 what was the year when he
ran 04 or 2000 one of those years when
he ran and he was way ahead of his time
that some of the stuff that he said if
he would have ran 10 years later 16
years later you know he would have won
or you know a lot of people talked about
that but some of the stuff he talked
about wasn't yet bought was there one
prior to this by the way can you check
if there was a campaign prior to this so
for me crypto you're seeing what
happened with nfts there's a lot of
people that are just not fans of nfts
crypto Bitcoin ain't going away the
convention is here every year in Miami
it's craziness you go there all the time
I do want to transition into another
topic here with what happened with
triple ratings yeah with our ratings
that came out and and Tom I want to go
to all of you guys I want to kind of get
all your feedback as well U.S stripped
of AAA rating by Fitch as budget
deficits at swellm this is a Bloomberg
story Fitch ratings down greater U.S
debt from AAA to double A Plus due to
Consumers over swelling budget deficits
with the federal deficit reaching a 1.39
trillion dollars for the first nine
months of the current fiscal year up 170
percent from previous year treasury
secretary Janet Yellen called the
downgrade arbitrary and outdated but
Fitch Justified the move citing
potential deterioration in the country's
finances over the next three years due
to tax cuts now spending initiatives
economic shocks and political gridlock
despite the downgrade the bond market
remained relatively stable but risk
sensitive assets took a hit with Europe
stock 600 index tumbling the most in a
month the downgrade underscores the
worsening U.S fiscal Outlook with Fitch
forecasting the debt to GDP ratio
to rise to 118 by 2025 more than two and
a half times higher than AAA median of
39.3 percent Graham when you see this
you're in the real estate space some
guys are saying it's not a big deal
you're overreacting stop this isn't
anything it's just this it's just that
you know and then there's some that's
saying this is pretty bad I mean you
know Kevin O'Leary came out said this is
not anything that's regular this is very
bad on what's going on here yeah where
do you stand with this I think a default
should never even be in the conversation
the fact that we even had headlines that
say oh the U.S risks a default it should
never even be a consideration the fact
that it is and it's being used as a
leverage point I think is awful totally
it shouldn't be used as that there
should be no question whatsoever that
the us is going to pay its debts on time
as agreed always so the fact that this
is being used is a possible scenario in
the past for negotiation I think is
awful but I mean they're not exactly
wrong with what they're saying so I do I
think in the long term is this gonna
matter probably not but I do think all
the concerns that they bring up are I
don't see any issue with them I mean
they're not wrong yeah I I totally agree
with you um and I think this is serious
and I actually
um disagree that this is not serious and
and you didn't you know the second part
of of of the of the of the you would say
in Spanish La noticia of the information
is the same week
that the federal government was
negotiating the debt ceiling increase
same week
Miami got a credit rating increase to
its highest level ever s p so you can
Google that Miami s p rating same exact
week
um so
running for president because we you
know I'm you know I'm here to talk about
Miami and what I did in Miami but I also
want to translate into how it makes me a
good presidential candidate I'm the only
candidate period that has cut a public
sector budget
full stop 20 the Delta between our
income and our expenses as a federal
budget is a 20 Gap right now
it's going to be ugly very ugly I've
done it it's going to be very ugly
number two I inherited a bankruptcy when
I got you know people look at Miami oh
14 growth this is great you know
whatever blah blah I inherited a
bankrupt City My City on day one 2009
when I got elected I was the only public
official that didn't get elected with
Union support because I wouldn't lie to
my employees I told them we're gonna
have to cut costs and it's going to come
out of you we're not going to raise
taxes and that's exactly what we did
okay we had to balance a 600 million
dollar budget
uh to 450 approximately 115 million
dollars we had to cut from our budget
115 one year by the way we didn't get a
four-year phase in a five-year phase in
nothing we now have the highest uh
reserves ever
highest we're going to have a super high
individual year Surplus and the highest
Bond rating ever we were fiscally
um sound we tightened our belt we did
things that government doesn't do which
is be disciplined and do what every
American does though every American
bounces a checkbook hopefully right and
and so what we should be promoting in
our country right savings like you said
and so I think this is a big issue to
your point they've postponed it till
after the presidential election which I
thought was
um you know I don't think that's a good
you know it's a good idea I think it's
wrong because so the next president is
going to have to walk right into that by
the way when I first got elected mayor
so I've confronted this deficit in 09 as
commissioner and then I had to
reconfront it as mayor because we got
sued by our labor partners 13 lawsuits
we won 12 out of 13. the 13th we lost at
the Florida Supreme Court okay it was a
700 million dollar liability on a fifth
on a on a in our budget
and I said to the guys I said look I
didn't lie to you in 2009 when I told
you we were not going to be able to
raise taxes and we're not going to be
able to increase your your compensation
we have to cut your compensation we did
tiered salary Cuts pension Cuts Etc
never done before in the history of
Miami
I'm not gonna lie to you now if you
bankrupt the city of Miami when we just
grew 10 and a half percent everything is
gone all your cookies all the stuff it's
all gone and they believe me and they
listen to me and so I negotiated that
debt down
for I think it was 18 cents on the
dollar from 700 million to 50 million
we'd even pay it all up front we paid
like 20 million up front and 10 million
over three years
um and so look it you have to that's
where the private sector public sector
experience is important let me ask any
word on Fitch and then I'm going to come
to you and then and then go ahead you
know first of all it's it's not what
happens to our bonds because Jamie
Diamond and Janet Yellen are saying two
slightly different things but they can
both be right Jamie dimon says it
doesn't really affect the US government
debt because the price is determined by
the market and people are still going to
be buying billions and billions of
dollars of government debt of the
countries like Japan and China that
speculate and Hold Us government debt so
that's going to change much what does
change is the waterfall effect and the
capital markets across the globe because
you saw what happened the European bond
market dropped so there was real loss of
value on one day in the European bond
market because Fitch drops on U.S and
although we've had headlines about
defaults have we ever defaulted you know
the debt ceiling is just the next
version of a Marvel movie and it's kind
of pathetic you know the world's going
to get saved you just look at your watch
and say it's going to be at about 2
hours and 15 minutes into the movie and
I think it's pathetic because I gotta
disagree a little bit with you on that
it kicks the can down the road every
time we raise the debt ceiling here you
I have to disagree a little bit with you
on that because I think what happens and
you see this in in the history of
conflict right to your point this debt
ceiling debate or whatever you want to
call it right
um it's it's a it's a standoff right a
Mexican standoff or uh you know and
what's going to happen is which is what
happens when there's nuclear war right
is sometimes neither side
flinches
right both sides dig in for whatever
reason whatever their reasons are and I
think to your point not solving a
problem continue to Kick the Can down
six months a year year and a half there
will be a moment where both sides will
dig in
thinking that the consequences will not
be as bad as as what they will be it
will happen and I think the I believe
personally and of course this is it's
like saying what is Putin going to do
next I mean who knows right who can get
into his mind
um I believe that the consequences will
be dramatic and dire that's what I
believe maybe it will never happen
because of that reason right maybe
hopefully or maybe a president like me
gets elected and decides we got to
balance our budget like this has to be
the number one priority because by the
way we haven't even talked about
inflation and interest rates or what I
call bidenomics the poor get poor right
in bionomics right uh through increased
through increased in inflation and
interest rates most people have their
money in bank accounts so they lose
purchasing power they want to buy a
house they gotta they gotta pay more
interest so they get squeezed on both
ends but if that doesn't happen if we
don't by the way we're living on
fictitious money
fictitious money I agree 20 right it's a
huge huge Delta I mean this is a huge
huge Delta so so to bring that back into
line it's going to take discipline it's
going to take pain and it's going to
take uh good tax policy that will grow
us out of it at some level but it's
going to take reducing expenses which we
hopefully are prepared to do mayor
swords I have a
sort of a policy and personality
um question for you right so
um you talked about the project possible
yeah right so there's maybe there's
people that's listening that are like
hey I like this guy yeah super like
whole guy but he's he's in Miami it's
Miami I'm in Iowa I'm in New Hampshire
I'm in South Carolina what is he going
to do for me right so
um number one how can you take the you
know the Miami model and and extrapolate
that for being the nationally and then
you know like we highlighted before
politics is so diverse right now but I
mean I don't know if the camera can
consensus you're a super likable thank
you aspirational positive optimistic guy
that's sort of your message for America
you know from a from a policy
perspective debt GDP like Graham was
talking about inflation but also just
getting along being a synergist coming
to to Washington how can you take what
you've done to Miami the Miami model
economically but also personality wise
what could you bring to DC well I think
I can I hope I can convey the
personality that I have the right
personality that I'm a consensus Builder
that I'm a unifier and that's based on
my record as getting like to buy 85
re-elected by 80 and changing a county
that was plus 30 for Democrats into one
that's plus 10 for Republicans based on
our policies but in addition to that the
biggest problems that we confront as a
nation
have to be confronted by someone who has
experience confronting them right and so
I would say the first problem is our
deficit and Rapid inflation and Rising
interest rates we got to get control
that I'm the only candidate you can look
it up you can do the research that has
actually cut a public sector budget by
the same percentage that we have to cut
our federal budget the only one that has
that experience right so I have the
personality the skill set and the
experience to deal with that problem
problem number two immigration I don't
think that there is a better person
capable of dealing with immigration
which is a multi-faceted complex problem
than a Hispanic Republican president why
because you got to control the Border
you've got to
um I think depowering China is a big
part of dealing with immigration and
it's we can get into that if you want
but it's a complex uh sort of analysis
uh you've got to deal with you've got a
right-size legal immigration and I think
that has not been pegged to objective
metrics like like growth like the need
for skilled and unskilled labor
um the declining birth rate Etc
immigration in terms of legal
immigration should be pegged to those
factors and should float with those
factors right so that we may need 2x 3x
the number of legal immigrants I don't
know what that right number is but there
has to be a formula to solve it for
America's benefit right and I think then
you got to deal with the undocumented
and I think a Hispanic Republican can
help demystify
um that problem as you were saying you
do this a lot in in Rogan's and and
you've done some of it today you know at
some level as as partisan politicians
were always counting votes right is this
going to benefit me as a party is it
going to hurt me as a party I'm not
likely to support a policy that may hurt
me as a party as I am likely to support
a policy that may benefit me as a pause
as a party and I think being a Hispanic
Republican president you are in effect
telling the Republican Party hey having
immigrants is a positive thing for this
country and
um if they're Hispanic this could
benefit the Republican party as opposed
to be a detriment you talked about some
of the polling numbers right we can
shift that and change that Dynamic which
changes the argument in many ways I
think if you wanted mainstream media to
get behind you and promote the hell out
of you to start you know getting the
polling to increase if you
made The Bold and brave decision of
being part of the lgbtq community I
think I think there's a big play there
as a mayor are you trying to compliment
my eyebrows no I'm just trying to say
man there's another guy that's a mayor
that did that and he was on every
magazine book story ever definitely one
way to get on there I don't think you're
gonna do it you've been happily married
for 16 years so I'm blessed let's let's
talk about let's talk about something
that's going on that's kind of uh weird
to me I take it in a weird way and I'm
really curious to know how you guys
process this okay
all of a sudden story comes out that Ron
DeSantis agrees to debate Gavin Newsom
on Fox News okay
so okay I mean you know because the
Newsome called them out Etc et cetera
and then all of a sudden they decide to
come in and say yeah you know I'm not
going to do it I'm not going to do it
I'm going to do it and now finally he
says yeah I'm gonna do it so Governor
Newsom agrees Governor DeSantis and
Newsom have tentatively agreed to debate
on Fox News a republican is vying for
the Republican Presidential nomination
while Newsome Democrat is supporting
President Joe Biden DeSantis agreed to
the debate saying absolutely I'm game
just tell me when and where Newsom
office had sent a formal request to Fox
News but proposed debate dates and both
Governors seemed ready for the challenge
the debate if it happens would be a
significant event in modern presidential
politics defense is Progressive
policies and Biden's record newsom's
office proposed three potential dates
debate sites Nevada Georgia and North
Carolina I don't know if you've gotten
the invite yet but they're thinking
about doing Nevada Georgia North
Carolina so Tom for for you how do you
process this so the way I see it is one
guy is not even a candidate Newsome okay
although he is uh we talk about this on
the the Rogan podcast he is I saw an ad
the other day for him raising money I'm
like what is he raising money for this
was like four days ago three days ago
you know so he's saying no I'm behind
biting all this other stuff the
scientist who's not in the lead Trump's
in the lead and Vivek is about to pass
up to santis and you got a bunch of
different things going on
this has never happened before it's not
like this is something that happens
every single time we've never apparently
this has never happened before how do
you process
a governor from a state that's not
running during election session would
Biden being the president and DeSantis
who is second place behind Trump saying
let's do debate the two of us yeah the
first thing I looked at was uh what um
Gavin Newsom was asking and I tried to
look up real quick the polling in North
Carolina because I know there are
Battleground areas in North Carolina but
it's predominantly Republican state
although shifting kind of lavender
um and I know why
yeah well you know not purple I got it
purple I got it and it's you know it's a
very nice lavender I'm trying to keep it
I got a visual well I was I was trying
to to defer to your recent announcement
um the um
[Laughter]
awesome
I know why he would want Nevada I know
why you would want Georgia I didn't know
why he would want North Carolina I was
trying to look up the polling here there
is a lesson and you're an expert on this
and you've probably seen this in
California too never agree to a debate
Mano Amano with anybody significantly
below you in the polls the only thing
can happen is you raise them up happily
be on stage with them because you can
talk around them or ignore them why
nobody wants to debate me in a in a
group right but but this is true this is
political strategy right I mean it's why
Trump is arguably not going to go to the
debate the first debate he said he's
going to wait to see who he take says so
I think that's a whole different Theory
I think this is bold by Newsome and if
I'm DeSantis I wouldn't have taken this
you're enabling him at a time where he's
trying to to raise even more stature
visibility and support I wouldn't on it
okay so what do you think I think it's a
sign of dissenses desperation
to be honest I think uh it's a
no-brainer for him he has to what have
been the big criticisms of him right
that he won't take on rough interviews
that he's sort of coddled that he's like
not
um willing to expose himself and I think
his advisors have told him that's over
uh you're not going in the right
direction you're going in the wrong
direction and the only way to shake
things up is to take risks right like
that's just the only way to change the
dynamic uh and and I think for him you
know this gives him volume right we're
all seeking volume at some level right
to make our case right we have to we
have to make our case with volume right
it's not the same you know being you
know and everything is an rot I call it
rot return on time all right like where
are you investing your time in terms of
how much volume you're getting to try to
get your message to connect I'm not
surprised at all
um it's a it will you know he now he
puts pressure on himself he's got to
compete he's got to do well
um and if he does if he does poorly
um I think it's you know I think it's
very very fatal and by the way who knows
if he's in the race in November right
it's another issue what do you think
about it Adam
no no I'm asking you what do you think
about oh gotcha this yeah uh I love the
return on time thing
um well it comes down to risk and reward
yeah okay
what's more of a risk and what's more
reward I I don't know why Ron DeSantis
isn't going on every big podcast out
there okay respect to you for sitting
down and answering tough questions and
being a part of this sure you know we
all know that political
uh candidates you know you can do great
on a five minute Fox News CNN segment
great you're polished you have all your
you know your words your scripts but
when a curveball throws your way you're
like oh [__] so DeSantis has whatever
reason not come on certain
big big big pucks big big podcast risk
reward I don't know let's say you lose
a debate to Governor Newsome Newsome did
to
um Sean Hannity yeah Hannity invited him
on like you're on Fox News you're in my
world about to like whip you around dude
Hannity ended up bloodied like it was it
wasn't good I mean you did better in
your fight than than Hannah did no doubt
but I'm curious I'm curious to know like
what do you think about that I saw that
news was a great speaker he's a great
debater I think for DeSantis it makes
sense that he might want to do that
because he he could get his face in
front of everyone who wants to watch
Newsome what I've noticed with Newsome
is that it seems like people who dislike
him and like him both want to watch from
a different perspective the people who
what a point the people who like yeah
want to see more often the people who
dislike him want to still want to see
more of them yeah yeah that's a very
good point so let me let me give my
thoughts on this on what I think so for
me
um
I think it's an insult if you ask me I
think it's an insult on on how it's
being done because if if I may if I'm a
a guy that's anti-establishment the way
I process this is here's two guys that
are saying yeah look we don't think
Biden you're going to be there and the
scientists Trump we don't think you're
going to be there you're being indicted
three times we don't think you're gonna
make it we're convinced the two of us
are going to end up at the end of the
day debating and we think a year from
now it's gonna really be the sentence
against Newsom so there's a there's an
element of arrogance to it there's an
element of make sense uh there's an
element of undermining two people
Newsome undermining Biden and DeSantis
undermining Trump so if if you do that
if you're part of Trump's campaign
there's a lot of different things you
can do you can come out and can say well
you know look at this guy he's desperate
you know he desperately needs to do this
because he just fired a third of his
camp and they're running out of the
fundraiser so they need to be doing this
they have to re-strategize their
marketing this is one of their ways to
get in front of that okay great
fantastic so that can be one argument
now let's go to the actual debate
um Rob put a poll I'm curious if we can
run a poll who do you think will win the
debate the actual debate Newsome or
DeSantis I'm actually curious what our
audience will say on who will win the
debate Newsome DeSantis not policies but
on TV who will win the debate between
due to policies as one of the areas but
who win the debate for you guys here for
all of us that are here who do you think
maybe I'm not going to come to you
because I think you know you're in it
Tom Graham uh Adam who do you think is
going to win the debate between the two
oh I was I was writing something down
because that way I made a prediction
before I saw the poll but I I think
65-35 news from DeSantis yeah I think
but newsom's also had a lot more
experience he's a great speaker so my
vote's probably Newsom I think uh with
the exception of GDP in California
because you could always be like we're
the where we if fourth what is it fourth
in the world okay great I mean that that
could always be the gold standard you're
not even close Florida but if you want
to compare resumes over the last couple
years
of who's done better
as far as people coming into your state
people leaving your state policies
coveted lockdown uh DeSantis has more to
run on
and what is what I think that's a good
Quant but lay it out for who do you
think wins the debate the way debates
are evaluated by consumers and voters
and things I think I think they're with
all due respect neither are are Stellar
uh human communicators like that I mean
I think Gavin Newsom is as fake of a
politician as it gets I we sat with
DeSantis policy wonk respect he knows
his policy thing I'd like to see how he
does it's a lot more personality we're
looking for numbers put it out
here's what I would say
um all the scientists has to do is talk
about a few different points first time
since 1851 you've lost people uh
California number two you need the
borders to be open
to show that your population increased
so the only way California can show that
its population increase is by getting
the borders to be open because the
people that are coming up the borders
they're going to be voting Democrats
most
64 65 percent of Hispanics vote Democrat
and it's even higher when it's lower
level income people that are coming to a
state like California so that's going to
be probably 70 75 percent so you know
newsom's going to say we've had the net
Positive Growth this year and that data
can be misleading and the census got to
show the only way you have a net
positive is because you left the borders
open okay so that's going to get the
crowd responding uh during covet no one
handled it better than the scientists
did what's Newsom going to say about the
santis the issue with Disney how is
dealing with Disney the woke ideology
stuff the books is going to say the
sentence is Banning books CRT blacks the
stuff that Kamala Harris is doing
DeSantis has to defend the slavery stuff
saying there was some good that happened
with black slaves newsom's going to go
after him hardcore on that if there's
anything they have to role plays what
that answer is going to be honored
because you can't just say Well it did
do so you can't you can't do that kind
of stuff it's going to hurt you then
they're going to say this Newsome's
going to come out and he's going to say
well listen if you think Trump is Right
descent is first further right than
trumpet so you definitely don't want
somebody like DeSantis because look what
position he took with Roe v Wade look
what position he took with this so it's
going to be a mess you know the Santa's
gonna go out there and say look in my
entire year I've been living in Florida
for 40 for 45 years I've never seen so
many license plates that are saying
State of California on it right he's
going to say that so uh debate skills
newsom's got it marketability and
getting eyeballs newsom's got it resume
it ain't even close who's got it the
Santa's got the resume but we're
learning in this election that resume
matters you need slightly more than
resume you need more I'll give you the
final thoughts on that before we finish
it up and as well as uh yourself if the
audience is listening to you right now
saying look Suarez you know I know where
you're right I know what you're doing
yeah you're doing a great job as a mayor
maybe it's good you run next as a
governor but president I'm not sure I'm
ready for you yet so if you got thoughts
understand this new Newsome give that
and then final thoughts we'll go to
before we finish up yeah I'll just say
that
um uh on that issue I would just say
that you like you said it's more than
policy you have to be able to to be
inspiring you have to be able to connect
with people you have to have the right
personality and you know you could you
know I don't think people thought of
trump as a policy wonk right I wouldn't
I wouldn't say that's the way he's
characterized uh so you know I think I
think uh you know politics is the art of
the possible and I think for me I would
say look look at a record
look at the success we've had look at
the qualities that I have as a person in
terms of being able to bring people
together in terms of being able to solve
big problems we live in a Washington
nice partisan world where everybody
wants to just blame the other person uh
and that's that's their solution right
call a press conference blame the other
side
um and and I you know I don't have the
luxury of doing that uh Republic you
know hurricanes are not Republican or
Democrat you got to deal with them uh
picking up the garbage is not Republican
or Democrat you got to do it right and
so uh I think I'm a doer and as
president it's time for us to have
someone who's different who looks and
sounds different a Hispanic be the first
time ever
um also a mayor be the first time ever
someone who's a problem solver and I
think that with my record I've shown
that I can bring people together and get
things done fantastic Graham yeah
um what's next for you man you're 33
you're millionaire you're doing great uh
we're gonna put the link to all the
channels so people can find you Rob if
we can do that below uh uh what's next
for you what should we say well we
talked about this a year ago I remember
clearly but I'm traveling now so we're
doing the podcast we've done so much
traveling over the last few months and
so I'm actually getting out there uh
going to the UK pretty soon so I'm just
seeing what else is out fantastic
excited for you man thank you Graham so
you had a question for Pat that you
wanted to ask him at the beginning one
over time over time so we'll do it now
all right we'll save it you can ask me
on your podcast
right oh okay we're doing that tomorrow
okay fantastic this was great
um gang tonight we're doing the live
podcast with vivec Town Hall at the
other Studio that we have the club uh
for those of you guys that are
florida-based I think it's already sold
out but if you want to stay updated for
the next live we'll be announcing for
another one that's going to be coming up
outside of this one text award podcast
to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast
two three one zero three four zero one
one three two take care everyone bye
Patrick David here from the Italian and
pbd podcast look once a year we host a
conference called The Vault conference
it's our Super Bowl where 3 000
entrepreneurs CEOs executive sales
people from around the world come
together to spend three and a half days
together from August 30th to September
2nd at the Diplomat Resort in Miami to
learn how to scale their business how to
identify their next 5 10 15 moves who to
recruit next who to go raise their money
from how to raise Capital how to
properly skill culture retention higher
fire all of those things and much more
and we do that over a span of three and
a half days and the reason why it's a
very important season to attend a
conference like this the following
reason today there's three different
types of people they're scared they're
those that are content and the obsessed
they're scared they don't want to do
anything because they're worried about
what's going to happen in the economy
they're going to take a big hit the
content they're walking around saying
life is pretty okay I don't need to do
anything else and then there's the
obsessed because they see a massive
opportunity today so imagine spending
three and a half days with three
thousand obsessed people that want to
grow in a season like this imagine how
much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event there's probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's going
to talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yet this is my recommendation
to you I never went to conferences when
I was coming up by myself I always went
with a spouse with a business partner or
running mate because I only have a lens
on what I see every night afterwards we
would sit there and say what was your
biggest takeaway so get yourself your
spouse your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]